وا كان تفشي وباء ايبولا في عدد من دول
غرب افريقيا التحدي الصحي الابرز في العام
2015 ومع اقتراب العام من نهايته نجح
العلماء في تطوير لقاح للمرض لينقذوا به
حياه ملايين الاشخاص
بارقه امل جديد بدات تلوح امام المصابين
بحم الضنك بعد الاعلان عن اكتشاف مصل مضاد
في المكسيك ما يفتح باب الشفاء امام كل
هؤلاء وباء اخر اعي العلماء والحديث هنا
عن الملاريا التي حصدت ارواح ملايين البشر
في المناطق الاستوائيه بحوث معقده يجريها
العلماء تهدف لمنع طفيل الملاريا من
الولوج الى كريات الدم الحمراء وتطوير
عقار بناء على هذه الفرضيه عدا عن مكافحه
الامراض الوبائيه يتوقع ان تسهم البحوث
الدقيقه التي تجرى على جنه في تشكيل خريطه
الحقل الطبي في العام
2016 وما سيليه اذ يتوقع ان تسهم في تشخيص
امراض مثل التوحد والشلل وغيرها من
الامراض الوراثيه في مرحله مبكره جدا
اضافات اخرى لا تقل اهميه اسهمت في تحسين
الاوضاع الصحيه في عام
2015 في عده مناطق من العالم لا سما في
العالم الثالث مبادرات يرى
انه لا غنى عنها في مناطق كقطاع غزه الذي
يرزح تحت حصار اسرائيلي منذ سنوات ولعل
هذا ما دفع هذا الطبيب الكندي الفلسطيني
الاصل طارق لوباني لاختراع سماعه طبيه
بتقنيه الطباعه ثلاثيه الابعاد انطلاقا من
تجربته الشخصيه ابان حرب غزه الاخيره
عندما كان الاطباء يضطرون لوضع اذانهم على
صدور المرضى لسماع نبض قلوبهم بسبب نقص
السماعات مبادره اخرى مسرحها قريه في
الريف الكمبودي يعاني اهلها من سوء
التغذيه ونقص الحديد جاء الحل من كندا
ايضا عبر سماكه حديديه توضع في طناجر
الطبخ لافراز كميات من الحديد يحتاجها
هؤلاء السكان
الفقراء